at president trump's inauguration he
spoke of american carnage
well he delivered there is
apparently nothing that president trump
cannot defile
as you probably know a right-wing
trump-supporting violent mob
breached the u.s capitol they broke
windows they blew past police
and they stormed both chambers of
congress they wore american flags
and were apparently incapable of irony
i remember i visited congress when i was
in high school the capitol is a building
that oozes history and unfortunately we
are witnessing
a history of a different kind
in the civil war the confederates only
made it as far as fort sumner yet today
a confederate flag flew inside the u.s
capitol
and today rioters lowered the american
flag
to instead fly a trump flag
and throughout it all like nero playing
his fiddle while rome burned
trump sat back and watched cable news
and apparently trump actually basks in
this mayhem
saying on twitter these are the things
and events that happen when a
sacred landslide election victory is so
unceremoniously and viciously stripped
away
from great patriots who have been badly
and unfairly treated for so long
in reality this is the most direct
attack on our capital
since 1814 and
they have delayed the certification of
our
democratic process it's hard for me to
even think of
a worse scenario for our democracy
the president and his supporters have
made the united states a laughing stock
now i'll compile my thoughts into a full
video on
whether the president and his supporters
have committed incitement sedition
and treason but apart from these legal
technicalities
we know who was responsible for today
as the president was on his dais he
incited the mob
going so far to say we will never give
up we will never concede it doesn't
happen
and after this we're going to walk down
and i'll be there with you
we're going to walk down to the capitol
and we're going to cheer on our brave
senators and congressmen and women
and we're probably not going to be
cheering so much for some of them
like a wannabe dictator he said because
you'll never
take back our country with weakness you
have to show strength and you have to be
strong
similarly the president's right-hand man
rudy giuliani demanded trial by combat
let's have trial by combat
by both incitement and omission
this president and his cronies are
responsible for what happened today
in one of the worst attacks on both our
democracy
and the physical buildings that are the
manifestation of our government which
are not always the same thing but today
life imitates art and they did their
damnedest
to attack both the idea of our democracy
and our democracy itself
the president failed to deploy the
national guard or properly
defend the capital both before the mob
arrived and
long after it started to attack the
capital
there's right now talk of implementing
the 25th amendment
as if his feckless cabinet members would
actually do it
but even if they would that's too good
for him if
one thing is certain today
it's that the president donald trump
needs to be impeached
and removed and i can't
help but draw an analogy to what
happened just a few
months ago in lafayette square you might
recall
that the president attacked unarmed
peaceful protesters in
a public street just so he could get a
cynical photo op
in front of a church and hold a bible
upside down
he was willing to employ every military
officer every federal employee with a
gun
to move aside these people exercising
their first amendment rights
so that he could get a photo op and it
turns out
and i have to admit i did not see this
one coming that you can
abuse the national guard and the
military and the police
by deploying them and also by
withholding them
which is what the president did today in
the face
of a violent mob that was armed to the
teeth the president turned a blind eye
i'm not talking about the people who are
protesting them all
fine that's you're right we're allowed
to disagree with each other
but as they turned their ire that was
stoked
by the president himself
the president was okay with it because
they were on his team
and there's a famous photo of troops at
the lincoln memorial in the summertime
wearing full fatigues prepared for just
about anything
but that wasn't the case today on the
day
that congress was supposed to certify
the results of the election
because these rioters were on the
president's team
they were loved by the president even as
they destroyed the government
he loved them and apart from the
complete lack of preparation
there were conflicting reports about the
national guard being deployed
at the request of the mayor of dc and
that it's possible that the department
of defense
refused to allow the dc national guard
to
protect the capital after it was under
siege
eventually the national guard from other
states were deployed
but it's indisputable that even they
weren't deployed except after extreme
delay
this would be comical if it wasn't so
sad and terrifying
it's the stuff of b-movie schlock like
white house down
the kind of thing that's popcorn fodder
because it's so hilariously
impossible and yet today in america
it happened it didn't take a foreign
military to invade
it took donald trump's incompetence and
finality
we're going to have to have a full
investigation as to how a
moderately sized crowd could breach the
american capital but
at the moment video appears to show that
it's possible that capital or
metropolitan police
were complicit in this mob and allowed
rioters through towards the capital
and eventually once the mob breached the
capital doors
some of the cops were taking selfies
with these terrorists
and don't tell me that the capitol
police are incapable of arresting people
i've seen capitol police arrest disabled
peaceful protesters before
and dragged them out by their crutches
and nationally
14 000 people were arrested during the
george floyd protests
it seems impossible but two incendiary
devices
probably pipe bombs were brought to the
capitol
many of these people were armed however
many arrests happened today
it's not enough and let's not forget the
senators and congress people who
promoted this
fantasy and engaged in these conspiracy
theories because they thought it was
politically expedient they forgot that
words have consequences
senators like josh hawley ted cruz
ron johnson kelly lefler james lankford
david perdue steve danes john kennedy
marcia blackburn mike braun cynthia
loomis
roger marshall bill hagerty and tommy
tuberville
thankfully some of those people are no
longer senators
and good riddance as my friends at crew
put it
trump loaded the gun and congress pulled
the trigger
remarkably some of these very senators
like senators holly and cruz have
actually been fundraising
during the insurrection as the mob
reportedly
rushed the two chambers of congress
senator romly reportedly excoriated
senator cruz
saying this was his responsibility that
he brought this
insurrection on and he's right
i was watching the floor debate this
afternoon in his objection on the floor
of the senate
senator cruz cited statistics about a
large number of americans who believed
in this ridiculous conspiracy theory
i understand your concerns but i urge
you to pause and think
what does it say to the nearly half the
country
that believes this election was rigged
if we vote
not even to consider the claims of
illegality
and fraud in this election which is
ironic because
a large number of people believe it
because people like him promoted the
ridiculous conspiracy theory
now cruz always a cynical politician
implied he didn't believe it
and didn't think that we should change
the outcome of the election but
said we should at least engage in these
objections
we're just asking questions we can't
tell them to
jump in a lake well with absolutely zero
respect senator cruz
these people can jump in a lake and
never come back
rioters stormed the state house in
michigan tried to kidnap the governor
and invaded the governor's house in
kentucky all the while certain
republicans continued to fan the flames
and in the face of an impeachment
perhaps a stronger case than in
watergate
they still played politics at one point
president trump in the debate famously
said with regard to the racist
organization the proud boys
stand back and stand by boys
stand back and stand by well they did
until today and to those of you who
voted for
these politicians you knew damn well
that they were snakes when you let them
in
and all while this insurrection was
happening the president made it
worse saying we love you you're very
special
even as they are literally trying to
bring down
the government he can't help but praise
them because
he thinks they're on his team his
attempts to
disarm these people via tweet or video
were so
laughably pathetic that twitter
suspended the president's account
because they were worried it was doing
more harm than good
which is probably exactly what the
president wants
he's not going to be president in 14
days so let it all burn
if we've learned anything from this
whole affair it's that we absolutely
have to impeach president trump again
remove him from office and prevent him
from taking any office again
this is a man who cannot hold power
there are 14 days left in this
presidency and that's far
far too long who knows what kind of
damage that he can do in that time
and the 25th amendment frankly is too
good for this man
at the very least we can't let him
pardon the traitors
who invaded the u.s capitol let alone
all of his cronies who
have done untold number of illegal and
immoral things
on the campaign trail president trump
said what do you have to lose
well it turns out everything but we are
stronger than this small man
we are stronger than this pathetic mob
members of congress are working through
the night to certify the election and
that's amazing
we already voted we sent donald trump
packing
and good riddance
we're going to rebuild the capital it's
just a building
and this is the last pathetic gasp of
the failed experiment of trumpism
and again good riddance
and thank you for showing the world just
how pathetic your movement is
how willing to engage in violence you
are
how all of your criticisms were in bad
faith and how you
are the worst of all of us how
deplorable
you are
your movement will die in ignominious
death and let this be a lesson
being a patriot doesn't mean wearing an
american flag
it means standing up for our
institutions and fighting conspiracy
theories
so let's unmask these traitors let's
ridicule them let's arrest them
and let's start with the one that
currently lives at 1600 pennsylvania